Okay, so welcome back to the computer
screen. Welcome to video number three,
where we're going to look at the
importance of gross domestic product, GDP.
Now, let's get into it. So, gross domestic
product, it's part of a discipline that we
call macroeconomics.
Okay. And as traders, when we're analysing
macroeconomics, we refer to this as
top-down analysis. So, basically, we're
looking at the larger economy, and looking
at everything from a top-down perspective.
Okay. So, for video three, what we're
going to do first, is we're going to
define gross domestic product, GDP, and
why it's so important in the world of
trading and investing.
And only when you understand this
importance, the importance of GDP, are you
really going to appreciate why we have to
build first, in our overall framework, a
macro view, a macroeconomic view.
So, we seek to build a macroeconomic view
and have an analysis from the top-down,
firstly, in our overall trading framework.
And if you recall the framework itself,
you'll recall that the majority of our
trade idea generation process is rooted in
fundamentals.
So, in front of us here, we have the
pro-trader systematic framework, 20 to 60
days time horizon, split up into the
theory and the implementation of a trade
idea and running a portfolio.
And on the left-hand side, within theory,
so our research, when we're researching
trade ideas, we are split up into
fundamentals and timing. And in the
majority, we are fundamental, which is
split up into quantitative and qualitative
processes.
So, from a top-down perspective, what
we're doing is looking at the quantitative
process through the lens of macro and the
top-down analysis. And essentially, what
we're trying to do here, from a
quantitative perspective, is look at
macroeconomic fundamentals.
We're looking at macroeconomic
fundamentals, okay? We're looking at
macroeconomic fundamentals, and we're
trying to predict GDP. If we can do that,
we can predict, to a large extent, stock
market returns.
So, before we get into that, for many
people that are new to macroeconomics, we
need to actually go through some
definitions that relate to GDP.
So, nominal GDP, this is the total income
of a country for a given year. Real GDP,
the total income of a country for a given
year, so nominal GDP, adjusted for the
level of inflation.
Okay? These are very, very important
definitions, but very easy to understand,
okay? But we do have to get them out of
the way, so there's no confusion.
Let's take a recession. A recession, two
consecutive quarters of negative, real GDP
growth, okay?
GDP itself. When economists and market
commentators refer loosely to, open
quotes, GDP, close quotes, what they are
really referring to is real GDP.
So, if you ever hear economists and market
commentators referring to it, that's what
they're referring to, real GDP.
They're not referring to the total income
of a country, nominal GDP. They're
referring to nominal GDP adjusted for
inflation, so real GDP.
Next up, correlation. If two variables are
correlated positively or negatively, they
move in the same, so positively or
opposite, negatively direction, okay?
So, if you have actually done the IPLT
video series, you will be familiar to an
extent with correlation.
So, if you have already seen correlation,
and coming to the first time, and coming
to PTM for the first time, and seeing
correlation for the first time.
It's pretty important to understand this.
Go to the downloads area of this video.
You'll see a PDF called basic statistics
guide, and that will take you through a
whole bunch of basics on statistics, but
also correlation.
So, go through that. It's important to
understand and have a basic understanding
of statistics and correlation as we're
building up our knowledge.
But, with correlation, it's pretty
straightforward. If there's two variables,
and they're correlated positively, it
means they move in the same direction.
If they go in the opposite direction, it
means they're correlated negatively.
Now, in the context of macroeconomics and
top-down analysis, we need some
definitions on indicators, okay?
And there's three indicators based on time
horizon.
So, there's leading indicators, coincident
indicators, and lagging indicators.
So, what is a leading indicator?
Well, a leading indicator is an indicator
that moves before the economy moves, okay?
A coincident indicator is simply an
indicator that moves at or around the same
time as the economy.
And a lagging indicator is an indicator
that moves after the economy actually
moves.
Now, don't worry about these definitions
too much.
Just for now, take them as they are, and
we will continue building up our knowledge
and understanding of macroeconomics,
top-down analysis, and GDP.
Next, let's have a look at the
relationship between gross domestic
product, GDP, company earnings, and the
S&P 500 direction and returns, okay?
Let's have a look at that relationship,
but let's first understand GDP and how
it's reported.
So, GDP is reported quarterly, okay?
And we have four quarters.
So, we have Q1, Q2, Q3, and Q4.
But GDP is reported after those quarters
are completed.
So, Q1 GDP, for example, and Q1 is
January, February, March.
Q1 GDP is reported in April.
Q2 GDP is reported in July.
Q3 GDP is reported in October.
Q4 GDP is reported in October, and Q4 GDP
is reported in January.
So, by its very definition, gross domestic
product, GDP, is a backwards-looking
measure of all the transactions that make
up the entire value of the economy.
However, the stock market itself
speculates on the future, so forward value
of companies via earnings, okay?
So, GDP is, by definition, a lagging
indicator.
However, the stock market trades every
day, Monday to Friday, and is therefore a
leading indicator to earnings and GDP.
So, if the S&P 500 is predicting earnings
and predicting gross domestic product, and
the stock market is open every day, and
earnings and GDP is reported in the
future,
then the S&P 500 is a proxy for forward
earnings and forward GDP.
We can use the S&P as an instrument to
predict earnings and GDP.
Or, in general, the stock market.
We can use the stock market and stocks as
proxy instruments to predict earnings and
GDP.
So, more definitions here inside the
top-down analysis remit.
When we're looking at variables, we
mentioned correlation earlier.
We're looking essentially here at two
variables.
In this context, we're looking at the S&P
500 and GDP, which we will come on to
later.
But, basic definitions when we have two
variables.
What can the outcomes be?
Well, there can only be four outcomes,
okay?
So, we have two variables, A and B, and
there's only four outcomes.
So, what are those outcomes?
Well, first outcome, variable A goes down
and variable B goes down.
They both move in the same direction.
Variable A goes up and variable B goes up.
Variable A goes down and variable B goes
up.
Variable B goes up.
They move in opposite directions.
And finally, variable A goes up and
variable B goes down.
Again, moving in opposite directions.
So, there's only a set of finite outcomes
that can occur.
Now, we're going to get into the S&P 500
and GDP and correlations there.
There's three downloads, however, that you
really need to get stuck into.
I understand in the downloads area that
support the slides on the screen.
Of course, you can look at this in your
own time.
You can rewind the video.
Go back and understand the commentary
around these numbers and what's actually
happening.
But, definitely download the Excel
spreadsheets and the PDF as supporting
material and resources
to fully understand what's going on here
and your educational development.
GDP is very important and S&P 500 returns
being linked to GDP is very important.
And it's our foundation for moving forward
in the video series.
So, download those spreadsheets and the
PDF and try to understand the numbers.
So, there's only two variables.
Now, we mentioned that there's only two
variables, A and B, and there's only four
finite outcomes.
Those two variables that we're going to
look at are the S&P 500 and GDP.
So, what we've got here is a table on the
left-hand side where we're looking at US
real GDP, quarterly GDP, and we're looking
at S&P 500 quarterly returns.
Okay.
So, you can see in the two columns where
we've got US real GDP and the S&P 500
returns with a six-month lag.
So, we have the level of GDP and we have
the level of the S&P and we compare the
two.
But the S&P 500 data is lagged by six
months.
So, what we're trying to do here is
analyze the relationship between US real
GDP and the S&P 500 data.
That is, and the S&P 500 data is lagged by
six months.
Why do we do this?
Well, if we look at quarterly GDP, okay,
and we compare it to six-month lag data
from the S&P 500, what we're looking at
here is whether the S&P predicts GDP by
six months.
So, if you look in the first row where we
have both pieces of data, where we have Q3
in 1950, okay, we have 2.338 trillion for
US real GDP and we have 17.29 as the level
on the S&P 500.
And you can see that the S&P 500 data
starts after Q3 or the end of Q3, okay.
And then every piece of data after that
is, again, lagged by six months, whereas
the GDP data is from that moment in time.
It's reported GDP data for that moment in
time.
And we do this all the way up to the
present day.
And we can analyze whether the S&P 500
predicts GDP.
Therefore, whether it is leading or not.
Is it a leading indicator of GDP by six
months?
Are the two variables correlated, okay?
Now, we do this very crudely, quite
simply, by looking at the four potential
outcomes.
So, we have the outcomes where they move
in the same direction and the outcomes
where they move in the opposite direction.
And we can assign simple scores to this.
So, if, for example, both the S&P 500 data
and the GDP data were reported down, what
we do is we assign a 0-0 scenario.
Okay?
So, we have a 0-0 scenario for the
outcome.
If the S&P 500 and GDP are reported up, we
assign a 1-1 score.
Okay?
If the S&P 500 is reported down and GDP is
reported up, we assign a 0-1 score.
Okay?
And if the S&P 500 is reported up and GDP
is reported down, we assign a score of
1-0.
Okay?
So, let's run through a quick example.
If you scan the data on the left-hand
side, and then we just randomly pick a
particular quarter.
So, let's pick Q1, 1956.
Okay?
So, just about halfway down the page, Q1,
1956.
We can see the S&P 500 level is 43.67.
And the GDP reported number for Q1, 1956
is 2903, $2.9 trillion.
So, $2.903 trillion.
And if we compare that to the row above.
So, we look at Q4, 1955.
The S&P 500 level in Q4, 1955, lagged by
six months, is 41.03.
Okay?
So, the GDP number is 2.914 trillion.
Now, when we compare that, what happens in
Q1, 1956?
Well, the S&P 500 went up because it went
from 41.03 to 43.67.
And the GDP number went down.
It went from 2.914 trillion to 2.903
trillion.
So, what do we do?
For the S&P in that row, we put a number 1
in the cell for the S&P.
Because the S&P went up during that
period.
For the GDP number, we know GDP went down.
So, we put a 0 in that cell.
So, what's the total here?
It's a total of 1.
And what is the scenario?
Well, it's a 1, 0.
What we also do is we report a total.
We record a total for S&P and GDP data.
So, in this example, in Q1, 1956, the S&P
was up.
So, we had a 1 score.
GDP was down.
We had a 0 score.
Therefore, the total is 1.
If we were looking at the row above, which
is Q4 1955, we have a 1-1 situation.
So, the total is 2.
And the outcome for a 2 total is when S&P
500 and GDP were both reported up.
So, we assign a score of 1 and 1, and we
get to a total of 2.
And we can analyze all of this data to
better learn and understand what the
relationship is between the S&P 500 and
GDP, and whether S&P 500 predicts GDP, and
to what level of accuracy.
Now, we're going to have a look at the
results on the screen.
You can obviously look at these in the
downloads area as well.
Download the spreadsheet.
Have a look at all the numbers.
Familiarize yourself with it.
And here's the results.
So, we have across the top, A, B, C, D.
So, the 0-0 situation is A. B is the 1-1
situation. C is the 0-1 outcome. And D is
the 1-0 outcome.
And what we find is this. Historically,
GDP explains 60.85%, which is the 1-1
scenario, plus the 0-0 situation, 8.19%.
Historically, GDP explains 69.04% of S&P
500 moves.
This is essentially when they move in the
same direction.
How do we know this? Well, we just total
these up.
So, if you look from left to right, in the
0-0 situation, this happens 23 times out
of 281 quarters.
That's our total data set, 281 quarters.
The 1-1 situation happens 171 times.
So, in the significant majority, 171 times
out of 281 cases.
And then we have the situation where they
move in the opposite direction.
We have 72 cases out of 281, where we have
the 0-1 outcome.
And in the 1-0 outcome, we have the
smallest amount in our data set, which is
15 cases out of 281.
So, we can see from the table quite
clearly that when the S&P 500 and GDP
don't move in the opposite direction.
Okay.
The majority of the time, it's because the
S&P 500 moves down and GDP doesn't go
down.
So, GDP is reported up.
So, in this scenario, what is happening?
Well, it can probably be explained by an
overextension in stock markets when we
look at stock market history.
So, what we have is a quarter of
profit-taking or price corrections in the
market,
whilst the underlying GDP, gross domestic
product, the growth in GDP remains strong
or remains positive.
So, overall, when these two variables move
in the same direction, S&P 500 and GDP,
when they move in the same direction, it
accounts for 69.04% of cases.
When they don't move in the same
direction, they move in the opposite
direction.
This accounts for 30.96% of cases.
Now, in the vast majority of times, when
they move in the same direction, so 60.85%
of times, they both move up.
Okay.
And then, in a small amount of cases, they
both move down, the 8.19% of cases.
And when they both move in the same
direction and go up, that's in the vast
majority, 60.85% of cases.
Okay.
Now, taken together, same direction,
69.04%.
If we look at the zero-one situation, this
is by far the biggest outcome.
When the S&P 500 goes down and GDP remains
up, GDP growth remains up, this is by far
the biggest outcome,
when they both move in the opposite
direction.
So, the 69.04 plus the 25.62, that's a
pretty significant number.
In fact, it's a very significant number.
Because, when you add these two together,
we get 94.66% of cases.
Okay.
So, scenarios A, B, and C, if we can
predict those situations, we have massive
odds in our favor.
But, just being able to predict them both
moving in the same direction, that gives
us still extremely good odds.
So, if we can predict GDP, and we predict
using the S&P 500 as an instrument to
represent our view,
69% of times, we're going to get it right.
The market is going to move in the same
direction as GDP, assuming that we can
predict it.
Okay.
So, let's just summarize this in terms of
prediction and what it means for a trader
or a long-short portfolio manager.
Well, if we look at scenario A, if we can
predict that GDP will fall, what are we
doing?
What action are we taking?
We're selling the stock market.
We're selling S&P 500.
Okay.
We're probably short stocks, net short
stocks.
If we're predicting that GDP will rise,
what are we doing?
We're buying the stock market.
We're going to have a long bias in our
portfolio.
Scenario C, where we get the stock market
going down, but GDP growth is reported up.
So, what are we doing here?
Well, we're predicting a potential
overextension in the market, and we're
predicting profit-taking.
So, the action that we're taking is to
sell the S&P 500.
Now, that doesn't mean that we're
necessarily short.
It just means that we could be taking
profits ourselves and having our risk
under control.
We could be short of the right stuff.
We can be long other stuff.
What we're doing here is just
understanding at the moment that there is
a scenario where we must, at moments in
time, based on historical data, predict a
profit-taking scenario.
The last scenario, scenario D, the 1-0,
where the S&P 500 is up, reported up, and
GDP is reported down.
Well, this is pretty unpredictable.
This is in the vast minority of cases.
Very unpredictable for a trader, portfolio
manager, to predict the outcome on this.
So, if it's unpredictable, we're probably
staying flat.
And what we don't mean by flat here is
that you have no position.
What we mean is that you've probably got a
neutral portfolio.
So, when we look at this historical data,
it does have some pretty profound
implications.
The first major implication for traders
and PMs is that if we can actually predict
GDP, so the 0-0 and the 1-1 fundamental
situation, okay, and on top of that, take
profits at the right times.
So, perhaps using technical analysis and
price action indicators.
Our market direction is going to be right.
8.19 plus 60.85 plus 25.62, so 94.66% of
the time.
That is huge odds.
And, obviously, it's not that easy to do
it.
It's not realistic that throughout our
couriers, we're going to be right 94.66%
of times.
But, what it does tell us as traders PMs,
the historical data, what it does tell us
is some profound stuff.
That when we're trying to use the S&P 500
as an instrument to forecast and back with
real money the direction of GDP using the
S&P 500, then we can have massive odds in
our favour when doing that.
And, remember, this S&P 500 data is six
months lagging.
So, what we're looking at here is S&P 500
data predicting GDP moves by six months.
So, the performance of the S&P 500, the
stock market, predicting the GDP move by
six months.
So, it's pretty profound stuff when you
look at the historical evidence.
And, again, of course, we're not going to
be able to do this all the time, every
time throughout our trading career because
markets are dynamic and markets change
over time.
But, if we can call the market direction,
60% to 80% of quarters throughout our
careers by predicting GDP, what GDP is
going to be six months from now, then if
we select the right positions, we can be
very, very profitable.
60% to 80% is still insane.
It's fantastic probability in our favour,
fantastic odds in our favour.
Now, if you've done the IPLT video series,
you will have seen all of the different
time horizons where we looked at various
methods to calculate odds and outcomes.
And one of them was day trading and day
trading the S&P 500.
You'll know that's essentially 50-50
throughout time.
The percentage probability here of being
right using top-down macroeconomic
fundamentals to predict GDP and therefore
predict S&P 500 returns on a quarterly
basis is a lot, lot higher than day
trading the S&P 500.
And this is exactly why professional
traders take this approach.
We're looking at macroeconomics and the
bigger picture and we're trying to predict
GDP and we're using stocks, the stock
market, as a proxy for GDP to predict the
future.
Okay.
And within the stock market, we're looking
at using stocks themselves as a proxy to
explain our overall view on GDP,
forward-looking GDP.
Now, if you've done the IPLT video series,
this will be familiar to you, where we
look at equity indices.
So S&P 500 volatility, we look at daily,
weekly, monthly and quarterly, and we
compare it to stocks.
Okay.
We compare it to volatility.
So if you look in the top left here, we
looked at the distribution of returns
analysis, the average standard deviation
of returns.
And highlighted there is the S&P 500
daily, weekly, monthly and quarterly
numbers utilizing the distribution of
returns method.
We also look, if you look on the
right-hand side, we utilized high and low
data and we looked at average returns.
And obviously, because high and low data
is wider than the narrow form of the DOR,
we get slightly higher results for daily,
weekly, monthly and quarterly.
But if we actually look at high and low
data for large cap and mid cap stocks,
especially on a quarterly basis, we can
see that the numbers are significantly
higher when looking at large and mid cap
stocks.
So if we look at the S&P 500 at 12.8%
high, low average returns from historical
data, we can compare that to large cap and
mid cap stocks of large caps, 36% and mid
caps around 53%.
So the high, low average returns for those
two data sets, large cap and mid cap
stocks, you can see the difference.
It's quite vast.
And you can also see this when we look at
the average true range percentage
analysis, the ATRP analysis, we get the
same results.
So we have another implication here,
another strong implication when thinking
about this in the context of predicting
GDP.
So if we can predict GDP and be right 60
to 80% of times in our careers, then we're
not only getting a far higher percentage
chance of making money versus say day
trading, which gives us the 50-50 expected
return of zero.
But we're getting a 60 to 80% chance of
making significantly higher returns.
Why?
Because we're not utilizing the S&P 500.
We're utilizing stocks, okay, which are
more volatile.
And specifically, we're utilizing large
cap and mid cap stocks as proxies to build
portfolios for our future view, our future
prediction of gross domestic product.
Now, we will come on to large cap and mid
cap stocks much later in the video series
when we're looking specifically in the
trade idea generation process when we're
looking at stocks themselves.
But for now, we have an entire portion of
the PTM video series dedicated to
understanding and predicting GDP.
Why?
Because it genuinely is that important.
Your macroeconomic view, your
macroeconomic outlook is extremely
important.
And it's the start of everything.
Now, we can also apply exactly the same
methods to other stock markets around the
world.
And this is a very, very useful exercise
to do because it helps you understand
stock markets around the world and their
link to gross domestic product.
In Europe, for example, when we look at
the main index there, which is the
Eurostox 600, and we look at Eurozone
gross domestic product, we get similar
results.
So if we run through these results
quickly, historically, GDP explains 72.28%
of Eurostox 600 moves.
So they're moving in the same direction.
When they don't move in the same
direction, the majority of the time, it's
because the stock 600 moves down when GDP
doesn't go down.
So again, we have this profit taking
scenario.
So you can see the numbers are very, very
similar to the S&P 500 and US GDP.
In the minority of cases, so only 4.95% of
times, and we're looking at a data set
here that goes back to 1995, only 4.95% of
times as the stock 600 moved up and GDP
gone down.
So what does that mean?
Well, it's a similar outcome as to when
we're looking at S&P 500 and US GDP.
If we can predict GDP based on fundamental
macroeconomic analysis, so FA, fundamental
analysis, and take profits at the right
time, so utilizing technical analysis and
price action indicators, we're going to be
right 95.05% of the time.
So again, stock 600 leading Eurozone GDP
with a six month time lag, the results are
extremely similar to the S&P 500 leading
US GDP.
Now we can also apply this to other stock
markets.
Let's have a look at it versus the
Shenzhen Composite leading Chinese GDP.
Does the Shenzhen Composite actually lead
Chinese GDP?
Well, if you look at the table,
historically GDP explains 55.75% of the
Shenzhen Composite moves.
And when it doesn't, the majority of the
time, it's because the index moves down
when GDP doesn't.
So when they don't move in the same
direction, it's in the vast majority of
cases that the Shenzhen Composite moves
down when GDP doesn't.
So GDP is reported up and the index is
reported down.
That happens 40.71% of times.
And then in the situation where the index
moves up and GDP has gone down, this is in
the vast minority of cases, only 3.54% of
times since our data set began, which is
1992.
And there is obviously a huge issue with
this, okay, because if you just take the
numbers at face value, the issue with the
Shenzhen Composite is it fails to predict
GDP almost as much as it predicts GDP.
Therefore, at face value, this is a very
unreliable indicator.
We'll discuss this in a little bit more
detail later.
Now, when it comes to the downloads and
looking at our data visually, let's go
back to the S&P 500 versus US GDP and look
at the 1950 to 2020 data set.
If we plot these two variables on a chart
together, we can see visually that there's
a pretty strong relationship between the
two, okay?
If we look at the stocks 600 versus GDP,
Eurozone GDP, and that's our data set 1995
to 2020.
So a shorter data set, even with the
shorter data set, you can see visually
that there's a pretty strong relationship
between the two.
When we look at the China data set, so the
Shenzhen Composite versus Chinese GDP, and
we've got a data set 1992 to 2020.
There's a relationship, but it's weaker.
You can see the blue line going negative a
lot more than the orange line, okay?
And they are the cases that we talked
about earlier in the 40% of scenarios.
Now, the method we were using up to now is
what we call in the industry a quad-nomial
method, okay?
This is the four outcomes of two
variables.
So when we looked at the 00, the 11, the
01, and the 11 outcomes.
So the outcomes for the four variables,
the four variable outcome method is called
the quad-nomial method.
And this is applied to the S&P 500 and US
GDP and global indices.
So indices in the rest of the world versus
their own country GDP.
And we mentioned it was a pretty crude
method, but the results are pretty
powerful, even though it's a crude method.
That's a very simple method, very simple
to understand, very simple to implement.
So you can do that basically for yourself
on any data sets that you can get hold of
online.
There's plenty of free data sets out
there.
You can definitely get hold of country GDP
numbers and stock market levels and pretty
easily implement that method.
What we can also do is take a more
sophisticated approach.
We can actually calculate a real
statistical correlation.
If you've been through the basic
statistics guide, you'll understand what a
statistical correlation is.
Here, we've got the S&P 500 versus US GDP.
And we've worked out a 10-year rolling
correlation from 1960 to 2020.
And in the downloads area, we've done this
for no lag, three-month lag, six-month
lag, nine-month lag, and 12-month lag on
the data.
And what we find is, is that the most
statistically significant is the six-month
lag for a statistical correlation between
the two variables.
Or put another way, an average 10-year
correlation of 0.56 for the S&P 500
year-on-year versus real GDP performance
year-on-year from 1960 to 2020.
Now, what does this do for our
understanding of the relationship between
the S&P 500 returns and US GDP?
Well, a 0.56 average correlation would be
considered by statisticians to be a
moderate correlation between two
variables.
Okay.
But it's positively correlated and it's
fairly high.
Okay.
That's the message we take.
But if we're trying to understand this in
a bit more detail, we can look at this
visually.
And we can look at the correlation numbers
going back throughout time and understand
when it's been high and when it's been low
and what may have been affecting that.
And this gives us a better understanding
and a better idea, therefore giving us a
better probability of knowing what to do
when trading stocks and trading the stock
market as a proxy for predicting GDP.
And we'll come on to that detail a little
bit later.
But for now, we know definitely that on a
10-year rolling basis, the six-month lag
is the most statistically significant time
horizon.
Let's have a look at the Eurostox 600
versus Eurozone GDP.
Because the data set is smaller, we're
looking here at a five-year rolling
correlation.
So we're looking at this from 2000 to
2020.
And we can see again that the six-month
lag gives us a pretty high number.
And around that, the three-month and the
nine-month gives us a moderate correlation
as well.
So the six-month is definitely the most
statistically significant.
But when we look at this visually, we can
see that the number was pretty high up
until the years of around 2014, 2015.
And then correlation started to come down.
If we compare this to the US data by going
back one slide, we can see when we look at
the US data,
correlation started to come down around
the mid to late 80s, in the period mid to
late 80s.
And it also came down massively in 2020.
Like I said, we will come on to these
explanations a little bit later.
Let's have a look at the Chinese numbers,
the Shenzhen composite versus Chinese GDP
on a five-year rolling correlation using
our data set.
So this will be from 1997 to 2020.
And what do we see here?
Well, we just see an average five-year
correlation of the two variables that is
extremely low.
Therefore, it's very unreliable.
So we can say with a very high degree of
confidence here that trying to trade the
Shenzhen composite based on your future
projection of Chinese GDP is a futile
exercise.
You can even see here that there's a
negative correlation using a 12-month lag.
Well, it's around zero.
And it's mostly around zero.
Nine-month lag, 8.6%.
No lag, 4%.
And in between, we've got a three and
six-month lag with an extremely weak, low
correlation.
So very unreliable in statistical terms.
This would be defined as having no linear
relationship.
Now, if we're going to understand S&P 500
and US GDP in a bit more detail, if you go
to the downloads area, you will see a
spreadsheet download there where we
actually have performed the statistical
correlation of the S&P 500 versus GDP.
And we're looking at, we've calculated the
10-year rolling correlation 1960 to 2020.
And what we're going to look at here is a
few things to try and better understand
the relationship between these two
variables when calculating a statistical
correlation.
So if we look at the top of the chart
here, which is our key, we can see four
things that we're measuring here.
If we look at the bigger chart, we can see
that we've got on the left-hand axis, GDP
growth year-on-year in percentage format.
And we've got S&P performance year-on-year
in percentage format with the six-month
lag.
So on the top, when we look at the key,
what have we got?
Well, first of all, in the pale blue dot,
we've got the S&P 500, six-month lag data
performance, okay, versus GDP.
So the correlation of those two, and we've
got the full data series in pale blue.
And how does that look visually?
Well, we've got a quadrant here on the
screen, where if you look at the pale blue
dots, you'll see top left, top right,
bottom left, and bottom right quadrants.
So let's run through these quadrants to
understand what we're looking at here.
If you look at the top left quadrant, what
is that telling us?
Well, the top left quadrant is the
scenario where GDP year-on-year percentage
is up.
However, S&P 500 year-on-year returns with
a six-month lag is reported down.
What happens when we look at the bottom
right quadrant?
Well, this is when GDP is reported down
and S&P 500 returns with the lag are
reported up.
So the top left and the bottom right
quadrant is when these two variables are
moving in the opposite direction.
And then the bottom left quadrant is when
GDP is reported down and S&P is reported
down as well.
So they're moving in the same direction.
And then you can see the top right
quadrant.
This is where GDP is reported up and S&P
500 is reported up.
So you can see and understand visually
here when we look at the pale blue dots,
the full data series.
The pale blue dots are showing us visually
that the vast majority of cases here are
when the GDP number is reported up.
And the S&P 500 number is reported up
also.
And then the second most common occurrence
is when GDP is reported up and S&P 500 is
reported down.
This would agree with our quadnomial
analysis.
However, we of course have outliers that
we'll come onto in a moment.
Now, if we look at the dark blue line,
this is the correlation number between the
line of best fit for the correlation of
the S&P 500 versus GDP, the full data
series.
And we can see from left to right, it's an
upwardly sloping curve.
It's a positive curve.
That means we have positive correlation,
which agrees with the work that we've done
so far.
Overall, when we look at the full data
series, we have an average 10-year rolling
correlation, 1960 to 2020, using the
six-month time lag of 0.56.
We know that.
So this is what we're looking at when
we're representing this visually, an
upwardly sloping positive curve.
Now, outlier scenarios and also a deeper
explanation of historical data and
correlation.
If you look at the case where the red
circle has covered the case, what would
you say this is?
Well, this was the situation in 2020
during COVID.
So we have a very extreme scenario where
GDP was reported down by a significant
amount, but the S&P 500 on a six-month
rolling basis, six-month lag, was reported
up.
What we've also done on this chart is
we've taken the period 1985 to 1995 and
had a look at this in isolation to try and
understand why the correlation was falling
from the mid-'80s to late-'80s onwards.
And how and why it was reported to be
very, very low in the early to mid-'90s.
Well, if we look at the 1985 to 1995 data
stripped out, this is the orange dots on
the screen.
And you can see that most of the cases are
in the top right quadrant.
Most of the cases are GDP and S&P 500 on a
six-month lagging basis, moving in the
same direction, and both are positive.
But there's a visual difference here that
you can see when you compare the orange
dots across the quadrants versus the blue
pale dots.
They're less extreme, okay?
The magnitude is smaller.
So if we look at the left-hand axis and
look at these orange dots, we can see that
the vast majority of times, GDP growth is
reported to be around between 2% and 4%.
But stock market returns are in most cases
pretty low and much lower on average
compared to the pale blue dots.
So when we look at outliers and when we
look at moments in history where
correlation has collapsed and been very
low between S&P 500 returns and quarterly
GDP,
we look for explanations and there are
some pretty obvious explanations.
If we look at the period 1985 to 1995 in
the bigger context, well, the period in
the 80s was a very, very high period of
inflation.
It was a very stark period in history, in
economic history of high inflation in the
United States.
And you can see in the early to late 80s,
interest rates in the US came down from a
very high level, pretty much for two
thirds of the decade, okay?
And in this period where, in the late 80s,
where interest rates went up, we ask
ourselves the question, why?
Well, inflation was roaring, inflation was
quite high and quite out of control during
that time.
And the Fed responded.
And you can see that rates went up in the
late 80s, stayed fairly high relative to
the low and didn't go below the previous
level until the mid 90s.
So this type of intervention from the Fed
could go a long way to explain what was
going on in the late 80s and early to mid
90s period in terms of stock market
returns and GDP.
Because in the backdrop, we had interest
rates rising pretty aggressively to
counter inflation.
And GDP in the background was still
growing at a decent clip, but the stock
market returns were not as high as
previous stock market returns.
So the magnitude of the moves in the stock
market were lower for the moves in GDP
that occurred at the time.
So what explains these moves?
Let's run through the breakdowns in
correlation between S&P 500 and GDP.
When we look at the statistical 10-year
rolling correlation, let's have a look at
these breakdowns and formalize the
explanation here.
So for the 2020 COVID situation, the
explanation is pretty clear, OK?
It's pretty obvious.
For 2020 S&P 500, the quarterly
year-on-year performance versus GDP, it
was in response to a massive Fed and
government stimulus.
There was a massive, big correlation
breakdown because GDP was hit in a massive
way.
And because of the massive Fed and
government stimulus, the stock market was
up year-on-year, six-month rolling
percentage basis.
So it's an extreme number that skews the
data set, OK?
And it's obviously an outlier, and it's
completely abnormal, OK?
So abnormal being it's not a normal
situation.
Now, we mentioned the period from the
mid-80s to the mid-90s for the 10-year
rolling correlation.
When we look at that on a chart for the
10-year rolling correlation, we can see
that correlation was coming down for the
entire period, OK?
And it really got low in the early 90s and
mid-90s.
That's when it got really low, OK?
What was the situation here?
Yeah, well, when you actually look at the
data set, and you can look at this in the
downloads area,
when you look at the data set for the
statistical correlation,
we can see that even though the data range
is pretty wide for the six-month lagging
stock market performance,
so the data range for the period in 1985
to 1995, it goes as low as minus 15% to as
high as positive 39%.
What we see, though, is that the data is
clustered in mostly 2% to 4% GDP growth
with lower stock market returns on
average.
What does that give us?
Well, when we look at the orange line, it
gives us a flat slope.
So, even though correlation was lower for
a period than historically, overall, the
correlation is still positive.
The correlation during that period in the
decade 1985 to 1995, when the 10-year
rolling correlation just trended down
continuously and then got very low.
Why did that happen?
Well, it was low because of the magnitude
of the S&P 500 moves versus GDP growth,
particularly in the early to mid-90s.
Arguably, how is that explained?
Well, probably the higher interest rates
coming through and affecting stock market
returns.
So, the period of the 1980s, when we look
in the bigger picture, it was one of very
high inflation due to aggressive interest
rate easing,
which in the late 80s, early 90s, was met
with a heavy Fed policy response in
reversal.
So, a period of higher interest rates,
which followed the huge decrease in rates.
Okay.
And when we look at the full data series,
including the 1985 to 1995 data, it has a
positive slope.
So, I'd encourage you to look at the data
set, download the spreadsheet, and have a
look at what happens during the early 90s
to mid-90s.
What you'll see is low stock market
returns associated with pretty decent GDP
growth, 2% to 4% GDP growth.
So, what does that mean?
The correlation was low because the
magnitude of the moves was smaller
compared to historically, and when
compared to the entire data set.
So, what lessons can we take here from S&P
500 and US GDP correlation breakdowns?
Well, the lesson we take from this,
firstly, is that the S&P 500 predicts GDP
in the majority.
But as traders, we have to understand that
when they move together, we will not know
with a great certainty the magnitude of
the stock market moves, especially when
they're going up because the range is just
so wide.
Okay.
Also, similar to our quadnomial analysis,
when we're looking at a statistical
correlation, when they don't move
together, in the majority of those cases,
GDP is positive and the S&P 500 is
negative.
So, this is defined as potentially
profit-taking.
Okay.
The S&P 500 goes down when GDP goes up.
So, the market arguably gets overextended
and then corrects.
Okay.
Now, additionally, shocks like in 2020 and
general Fed intervention, we take the
message from the statistical correlation
analysis.
We take the message that shocks like 2020
and general Fed intervention can create
lower correlations.
But on the whole, we tend to, as traders,
towards positive correlation and
predicting GDP and therefore stock market
returns via earnings, but with an unknown
magnitude of the move.
And this brings in a general point here,
guys.
You know, retail traders are generally
kind of always looking for a rule book,
looking for a checklist of things where,
you know, if you take a whole bunch of
boxes, then something is a trade or an
investment.
And as long as you check all the boxes,
you're going to make money and make a
certain amount of money.
Well, you can see from here when we look
at our statistical correlations that we
can't predict with a great amount of
accuracy the amount of money that we could
make.
What I'm referring to here is the
magnitude of a particular move in the S&P
500 when predicting GDP.
Yes, we have statistical correlation, but
the range is wide.
And therefore we have to be very careful
in saying that there's some sort of rule
book here where if we have 2.65% of GDP
growth, we're going to get a certain
amount of stock market return.
That's just a fallacy, okay?
When we look at the statistical
correlation through our history, we can't
infer a rule book.
We can't infer that if we get a certain
amount of GDP growth and predict that,
we're going to get a certain amount of
stock market return.
What we can infer is that there's going to
be very likely a statistical correlation
and a move that we can explain in terms of
GDP.
Therefore, we can set ourselves up to have
the odds in our favor, but the odds will
never be a hundred percent in our favor.
It's not a rule book.
It's not a Lego set.
It's not a Duplo set where we plug and
play and get a certain amount of GDP
growth and a certain amount of stock
market return,
and therefore a certain amount of money in
our trading accounts as profit.
It just doesn't work like that.
But what we can do as traders and PMs is
try our damned hardest to predict GDP.
So we have a macroeconomic view and we
have the odds in our favor.
That is way better than taking other
approaches to trading, especially the
retail trading, day trading or very short
term approach,
not trading on fundamentals and trading on
noise.
Okay.
Now, coincidentally, this is exactly why
we have a long short mandate as traders
and PMs.
If we're long short when there's shocks
and or intervention from the Fed and or
correlation breakdowns, what's going to
happen if we're running long short
portfolios?
Well, our portfolios, we can say, will
probably outperform the index.
Okay.
And they will outperform long only
strategists.
So long only traders and investors and
will definitely outperform traders who
haven't got a clue that this even exists.
Additionally, we can also react to these
situations for outsized returns.
So the absolute return mandate.
Again, guys, we're not really interested
in measuring ourselves against the index
or against long only traders and PMs and
traders who don't know what they're doing.
We just want to make money when the market
goes up and the market goes down.
Okay.
We just want to make money in all
scenarios.
So we can also react to these situations.
We can also predict these situations.
So the situation, for example, with the
zero one, where we believe stock markets
have become overextended, we can get
neutral or short in our portfolios after
having a long bias and make outsized
returns for the absolute mandate.
So we can predict, we can react, we can
massively outperform.
This is why we have the long, short
mandate.
This is why we do it.
It's one of the main reasons.
So we know by taking the top down approach
where we're trying to predict future GDP
six months out and we're utilizing stocks
to, as a proxy, to make money from our
view on GDP and earnings.
We take this approach, but, and we know at
the same time, the odds are in our favor,
but we know that it's not a hundred
percent.
We know we can be wrong.
We know things can go against us.
We know there's statistical outliers that
can occur.
This is one of the main reasons why we
have a long, short mandate, and you can
see it in the numbers now.
So this is a very good learning experience
for everybody.
And, you know, in terms of educational
development, it's a fantastic foundation
to download those spreadsheets and really
understand the numbers and map the
outliers.
Understand statistical correlation,
understand the quadnomial, understand
stock market history, and transpose a
trading strategy onto the data and onto
the market that's going to give you a
fantastic chance with odds in your favor
in all weather conditions.
Now, let's have a look at GDP globally,
because it's always good to understand
that, to make our educational foundation a
bit stronger.
Let's have a look at the top 25 countries
in the world by nominal GDP.
Taking the data in 2019 in US dollars.
And that's from the IMF.
Okay.
So we're looking at the table on the left.
You can see United States at the top there
for 2019.
Let's try and understand some of these
numbers when we look at all the countries
that are in the table here.
So if we look at these numbers and break
them down to try and really understand
global GDP, the US economy was 1.5 times
larger than China, which is the second
largest economy.
So if we add up, if we add up the 23
economies in the 25 below the United
States and China, what do we get?
We get to 37.4 trillion dollars.
Okay.
So the United States is 21.4.
China, 14.7.
And the rest is 37.4 trillion.
The US is 57% of this number.
Okay.
It's still 57% of all of those economies
added up.
And China is just under 40% of that
number.
Now, to give you an idea of how big the US
economy actually is when compared to the
rest of the world, let's do an exercise
here where we add China to that number to
make it 24 economies instead of 23 outside
the US.
Well, when we do that, we get to 52
trillion and the US is still 40, 41% of
that number.
So this gives you a lot of perspective in
understanding how the world economy works.
If we look at China itself, 19% of China's
GDP is exports and 19% of those exports
are to the United States.
So we just do a multiplication, multiply
through, and we work out how much that is
in dollars.
It's equivalent to $531 billion in 2019.
The US is China's largest export market.
This gives you an idea of how the global
economy actually works here.
The US economy drives global GDP.
It absolutely drives global GDP.
It's by far the most important task as
traders when we're predicting GDP is to
predict US GDP.
Now, we can also look at the Eurozone in
2019.
So there's 19 member states of the
Eurozone.
And we have to consider the Eurozone a
single economic area because they have a
common currency.
Okay.
When we look at the Eurozone in its
entirety, the Eurozone is 62.2% the size
of the United States
and 90% the size of China.
Now, global real GDP in 2019 was 87.5
trillion.
The US was just under 25% of that number.
China was just over 18% of that number.
The Eurozone was 15.5% of that number.
If we do the exercise where we add the US
plus China plus the Eurozone in 2019, what
do we get?
We get to 49.5 trillion US dollars.
What does that mean?
That's 56.5% of global GDP.
Okay.
Now, when we take it into consideration,
the US, Eurozone and China, it is way more
important
to predict US and Eurozone GDP together in
order to build a global macro view.
Why?
Because China is so heavily dependent on
the rest of the world.
And also, China GDP is just notoriously
difficult to predict.
We'll come on to those reasons in a
moment.
What conclusions can we get here when
we're looking at stock markets leading
GDP?
Well, although occasionally, the US and
Eurozone equity indices versus GDP
correlations fall dramatically.
Historically, and on average, using a
six-month lag, stock markets are a
reliable indicator in predicting GDP via
positive correlation.
They move in the same direction in the
majority of times and with fairly high
correlation most of the time.
And this is backed up by our quadrenomal
analysis using the six-month lags.
The US, 69%.
Eurozone, 72% of times.
The index and GDP move in the same
direction.
So, this is the situation in the
quadrenomal where we have the 00 and the
11.
And in the statistical correlation
analysis, it's in the quadrants top right
and bottom left.
Most of the times when these two variables
do not move in the same direction, it's
because the index moves down and GDP goes
up.
Okay.
This is down to potential short-term
overextension, which leads to
profit-taking in the index.
Okay.
Now, GDP is relevant to traders and PMs
because it helps us understand the growth
potential in the economy and the positive
correlation to company, so stock earnings.
Okay.
Additionally, if we can predict
forward-looking GDP, what are we doing?
Well, we are predicting forward-looking
company earnings on the whole, on a
wholesale basis across the market.
Okay.
We are predicting forward-looking company
earnings through positive correlation.
And we trade with a long-short bias
depending on our view or prediction of
expansion or contraction in the economy.
Now, we know by looking at the data,
expansions last longer than contractions.
So what does that mean on a company level?
It means earnings growth lasts longer than
earnings contraction.
Economic growth, GDP growth lasts longer
than GDP contraction.
However, when GDP is expected to contract,
obviously we can't reasonably expect
earnings to be growing.
If at any moment in time we predict, for
example, that GDP growth is going to
contract in six months' time, of course,
how can we reasonably expect earnings
growth to be positive?
We can't.
So our expansions, we know, last longer
than contractions at a GDP level and an
earnings growth level.
When GDP is expected to contract, of
course, we are thinking that earnings
growth is going to contract too.
So overall, GDP growth and predicting it
is very relevant to traders and PMs
because we need to understand the growth
potential in the economy and the
subsequent growth potential in company
stock earnings.
Now, let's move on to the basket case,
China.
When we're thinking of this
geographically, globally, I'm thinking
about stock markets leading GDP for each
economic region or country.
China GDP and stock market returns, when
we look at statistical correlations and
quadnomial data, they're a basket case.
Why?
Well, because much of the Chinese GDP
growth that occurs is not corporate
growth.
The government has a hand in everything.
Okay.
It's very much public sector driven.
And the data can also be heavily
manipulated.
This is why Chinese GDP growth is
notoriously difficult to predict.
A lot of the times the numbers are made
up.
They are fantasy.
Okay.
Attempting to position in Chinese stocks.
So American depository receipts, Chinese
stocks on the New York Stock Exchange.
Attempting to position in Chinese stocks
based on a view of Chinese GDP is very
obviously a futile.
We will come on to China much later in the
video series.
But for now, we just need to understand
the data and continue to build our
understanding and educational foundation
in stock markets leading GDP and looking
at them around the world.
Okay.
What we're really interested in is the US
and Eurozone GDP.
That's what we're really interested in
because that's what drives global GDP.
What we're trying to always understand
here as traders, portfolio managers, is
the bigger macro picture, the bigger macro
economic picture.
We're always asking ourselves the
question, which way is the wind blowing?
And asking ourselves the question, how
hard is the wind blowing?
What does this mean for the bias in our
portfolio?
Should we be long?
Should we be short?
Should we be neutral?
We also ask ourselves the general question
that we learned in the previous video
series.
Are we in a bull market?
Are we expecting expansion?
Or are we in a bear market?
Are we expecting contraction?
So these are the reasons, guys, why we
look at stock markets as a leading
indicator to GDP and company earnings.
We want to be setting ourselves up for the
direction that the wind is blowing in.
Trying to calculate some sort of
expectation for how hard the wind is
blowing.
Setting our portfolios up with a bias,
long, short, neutral, and understanding
the context that we're in.
Are we in a bull market where we
experience expansion?
Are we in a bear market where we're
experiencing contraction?
What is our expectation for the future?
And how do we want to be set up?
So this is a great general fundamental
level of understanding, guys.
Just a little note before we go back to
the desk and onto the next video.
When you're downloading data from public
sources, GDP data, okay?
GDP data is subject to revisions.
So please, in the future, do not contact
ITPM and tell us our GDP stats in the
downloads area do not match your stats.
There's always going to be small
differences because of future revisions by
authorities in the country that you're
looking at, okay?
Just look at what we've done as a
template.
Repeat the same processes that we teach
you here and you will get the same or very
close to the same results, okay?
There's not going to be much difference.
Use what we've told you as a template and
practice, practice, practice.
Go through the data yourself.
Go through the spreadsheets.
Go through the exercises of building the
spreadsheets yourself.
And you will get to the same or very close
to same results.
Please do not send us messages telling us
that our data is slightly incorrect
because there will be revisions to GDP
data.
Okay, guys, let's go back to the desk for
a quick recap and then we'll go into the
next video.
Okay, so we got into some pretty hefty
data sets and concepts there.
It's great to break you in quickly and
throw you into the deep end.
I know it's a little bit uncomfortable,
but don't worry.
You will learn to swim much quicker than
you expect.
Just use the spreadsheet downloads and
bring yourself up to speed using the basic
statistics guide PDF.
Now, the main point here to get from this
video is that as traders, we use
macroeconomics as a tool to forecast stock
market direction.
The tool of GDP direction is not, of
course, 100%.
Nothing is guaranteed in financial
markets.
But in the US and Europe, it explains
around 70%, 7-0, 70% of quarterly moves in
the stock market historically.
Now, when it doesn't explain the move, in
the vast majority of cases, it's because
the market has gotten ahead of itself.
And it falls before GDP is printed up.
And we characterize these periods as
corrections or periods of profit taking.
So, if we can predict GDP direction and we
get it right, that we're going to have a
correction.
So, we get it right in those periods where
expectations get ahead of themselves and
they are too high.
Then, we stack the odds in our favor.
And this approach is way better odds than
simply day trading at 50-50 odds.
So, we use indicators as traders to
predict GDP so we can gauge which way the
wind is blowing and position our
portfolios accordingly.
Now, we can't tell how much the market is
going to go up or down in percentage terms
when we have the S&P 500, for example,
predicting GDP.
But we can predict the direction with a
high degree of certainty.
And this for us as traders and portfolio
managers is good enough.
We essentially expose ourselves by taking
this approach to potential outsized
consistent returns.
So, as traders, we forecast GDP direction
and therefore stock market direction and
potential returns via what we call leading
indicators.
So, macroeconomic indicators that lead the
economy or economic GDP growth.
Now, we're going to start here with our
first set of indicators to predict GDP and
stock market direction and potential
returns.
We're going to do a deep dive into the
bond markets.
So, in video 4, we're going to look at
sovereign bonds.
So, real interest rates and the yield
curve.
And in video 5, we're going to be looking
at corporate bonds and credit spreads.
These are very important indicators for
predicting economic growth direction and
therefore stock market direction and
potential returns.
Also, these indicators are a gauge of
liquidity in the stock market and both
stock market direction and GDP growth
direction are also a function of
liquidity.
And it all starts in the money markets.
So, interest rates and bond markets.
So, let's get into the next video.
And I'll see you back here at the desk at
the end of video number 4.